if you had the power to come back from
the dead what would you do the
government wants to capture and
experiment on you forever and now
everyone else including your parents
either wants to help them or kill you
for bounty i'm going to break down the
mistakes made what you should do and how
to beat the black ghosts in ajin this
kid doesn't know this but he's about to
die a brutal death kay here is a normal
kid living his boring life when on this
particular day something seems off in
class they learn about ajin a group of
supernatural beings thought to be
immortal this group was discovered 17
years ago in africa and since then have
been hunted by the government with
massive bounties being placed on them
all over the world however the teacher
says that any one of them could be najin
as no one knows until they die and come
back to life later on k heads home but
is in his own head just as he crosses
the street then suddenly a huge truck
hits him running over crushing his body
and killing kaye in the process his
lifeless corpse just lays there in the
middle of the street but this is only
the beginning the crowd suddenly gathers
near the crashed truck when something
insane happens kay wakes up covered in
his own blood good as new as his body
emits a mysterious black smoke and he
begins to freak out he's an ajin and now
the world is coming for him okay okay
let's not panic but we need to get our
heads in the game here even if we could
trust our friends which we can't they
wouldn't be able to help us as they are
kids after all and like what we learned
from our teacher there's a massive
bounty placed on our heads which means
we can't trust anyone we know our own
home isn't safe anymore and so i would
first head to an atm away from the crime
scene and take out as much cash as i
could and i'll also get a new change of
clothes because i'm bloody as all hell
the next thing that i would do is head
to a convenience store and get some food
that will last us a few days hear me out
now it's safe to say that the first few
hours after the accident is when we'll
have the best chance to not be spotted
as the news works to catch up with the
current events meaning we don't have to
worry about cops yet and that also means
that we should have a little bit of time
before our own face is plastered all
over the news we're going to have to be
content with giving up our friends and
family at least for the foreseeable
future especially if being in a gin is
considered to be as insane as people
make it out to be and we can't go
anywhere where the cops would think to
look for us the first thing we need to
do is to get out of this highly
populated area japan is a land of
forests and mountains with some 25
million hectares covering 67 of the
country this means that i'm going to
make my way out of town to a heavily
forested area to use as cover as i plan
my next few moves kaye is freaking out
and there's a bounty on a gin which
means he can't even trust his own
friends he runs off quickly before the
ambulance and police arrive he thinks
his life is over but actually it's just
starting and it's about to get a whole
lot worse kay runs into the forest and
is terrified he notices flashing lights
in the distance where his house is the
cops have already showed up at his home
which means nowhere is safe he decides
to call a childhood friend kaito who we
see is already packing a get out of town
bag how convenient just then a policeman
spots him and he makes a run for it he
can't trust anyone not even the law
itself kay rushes through the trees and
bushes until he trips and injures
himself the police is almost on him
suddenly kanto jumps out of nowhere and
knocks the policemen out as the two run
towards kaito's bike kaito has a plan
for them to head up north to a far away
village but what he doesn't know is that
they'll never get there meanwhile this
mysterious white-haired guy here shows
up at the police set up near kaye's
house he's from the ministry of health
and is an ajin hunter expert he tells
the cops how to really catch a jinns
using tranquilizer guns as he prepares
them for the deadly hunt that will now
span all over japan he also sent his
assistant to go check and see if k
sister who is recovering in the hospital
knows anything but this will cost him
and his assistant a lot more than they
think back on the run k and kaito are
filling up on gas as they notice a van
coming they quickly rush off but it's
too late the two men of the car
recognize kaye's face as his identity is
now all over the news the boys
eventually stub again as kay needs to go
to the bathroom but just as kaye waddles
off behind the bushes to go pee he's
attacked by the men following them in
the van my oh my two young kids not
thinking things through hollow original
kay and kaito are acting too carefree
about this situation and are acting like
freaking idiots k has an end with kaito
as he is not wanted or affiliated with
kaito in any significant way at least on
paper as of yet this means that kaito
could have gone places without drawing
attention this also means that kaito
should have dropped k off a few feet
before or after the gas station and
should have filled up the bike alone
with k waiting in the bushes nearby or
something even if there was no passing
cars at that time japan is a country
with around the same amount of cctv
cameras installed as the united kingdom
with around 6 million cameras nationwide
these kids were just asking to be caught
and while we're at it if i was escorting
a friend across the country and he was a
super mutant i would at least start
googling what it means to be an ajin
this way we could have just let k die
without helping him knowing that either
his ghost or k himself would come back
from the dead to kill those guys and if
what we read online was wrong ah then k
died sucks to be him we could have gone
back home anyways problem solved the two
men violently beat up k and kaito tries
to stop them one of them accidentally
kills k by choking him but that's when
casey's the most horrifying thing a
black ghost as his mind wanders outside
of his body for a second as he finally
wakes up and this time pissed off k
emits a loud piercing scream that
paralyzes everyone including kaito for a
second kay yells at kaito to get moving
giving kaito the shock that he needed to
shake it off giving the boys enough time
to escape as kaye tries to figure out
what the hell that terrifying black
ghost was back in the van the two men
catch up again near k just as they are
stopped and paralyzed on the train
tracks by something and that's when one
of them looks up and sees a dark black
sinister figure echoing k's words from
its faceless mouth the man screams in
horror as the train kills them but these
two boys can't catch a break as they
moments later pass a man on a motorbike
who spots case face and that's when the
chase is on hold on hold on seriously
you're a wanted fugitive and you
couldn't even afford to wear a scarf
over your face or a mask the whole
country is looking for you like what are
you doing kay should have been a greedy
bastard like us and swapped for the
better more face covering helmet with
kaito this was an easy fix motorbike man
forces them off the road as king kaito
crash seemingly killing kaito and badly
injuring k motorbike man comes near k
and is about to kill him kaito then gets
up he's alive and pissed as all hell and
beats the [ __ ] out of motorbike guy with
a rock unfortunately for kay he can't
move due to his leg being broken k wakes
up seconds later reset and good as new
the two boys then stop over at kaito's
safe house to fill up on equipment for
the long journey ahead kay and kaito
then discuss plans for the next step of
this escape plan as kay wants to just
live in peace so kaito suggests that his
village again is a possible option as he
claims it's a place where no one would
care if he wasn't a gin kaito then lets
kay rest as he goes off to the nearby
store to get some supplies k knows what
kaito doesn't that this journey is too
dangerous for a human and one that will
cost a lot of lives elsewhere the
assistant of white-haired man shows up
at the hospital to see if k sister knows
more about kay and aegin's than what she
already told the cops and this is when k
sister mentions the scariest thing ever
she claims that when she and kay were
kids their pet suddenly died and that's
when kaye mentioned that there was this
faceless black ghost hovering over their
bodies but she personally couldn't see
anything there herself this stuns the
assistant and her face gives off more
than she realizes but just then her body
contorts violently up in the air as she
gets stabbed by something and then her
chest bursts open with blood it's a
black ghost and only she can see it
kaye's sister screams in horror as the
assistant's lifeless corpse thumps back
down to the floor the invisible monster
then ends up killing and ripping
everyone apart in the room as the sister
can only watch in terrifying fear she
can't see what we can that there's an
insanely huge and blood curdling monster
in the room with her and that's when the
assistant comes back to life turns out
she's an ajin too shit's about to go
down but the only thing we have on our
side is the fact that other people are
in this [ __ ] show with us my thinking is
to fight fire with fire and set this one
out until everything goes to ship so
what if we brought some more people into
this room to add as a further
distraction hospitals usually have a
button or a switch nearby on the
patient's beds to alert the nurses when
patients are in need of something so i
would have pressed that button and told
them that i was in need of assistance
and dashed out of that window and waited
and watched as more unsuspecting nurses
would have come in this would no doubt
cause a bloodbath to occur resulting in
many deaths then as this [ __ ] show went
down i would have either waited until
whatever was going on was over or i
would have worked on finding a way down
or at least away from this main room
because let's be honest what else could
we have done aside from stirring up more
[ __ ] and we love stirring up [ __ ] the
assistant fights this black ghost with
her very own and they fight each other
to the death tearing each other's limbs
apart and knocking each other around
until the assistant's black ghost kills
the other one striking it with blunt
force trauma to the head and we see the
fallen black ghost being controlled by
mr douchebag right outside but this all
turns out to be just a distraction as
now k sister has been taken by the
infamous ajin called sato or the man in
the hat secured in an unknown location
later sato asks k-sister all about k and
she spells everything there is to know
about her brother until sato knocks her
out then back at the safe house kay
forms his own game plan using what he
already knows about japan's statistics
according to the ministry of labor if
over 1 million people in japan die every
year that means two people die every
minute which means some of them must be
a jinn kay leaves the safe house as
kaito remains sleeping unaware kay
doesn't have much time until he is
discovered so he needs to act fast
deciding that he'll find the rest of the
agenda hiding through the internet he
sets off okay i'm just going to comment
on how unbelievably stupid this is you
have a friend willing to help you yet
you're too high and mighty and noble to
let him in on your adventure you're a
kid with no money food or supplies kaito
has a safe house a village and even a
bike remember he even packed a duffel
bag from earlier he's way more prepared
than kaye is this is why i wouldn't
ditch him at all in fact his plan sounds
solid enough aside from the fact that
they may be rushing to kaito's village
at a time when roadblocks and alerts for
k's whereabouts will be at their highest
and kaito hasn't even been discovered
yet so we could still use him to
continuously supplies with food and
water when we run out as we wait for the
heat to die down on us but even then i
would consider avoiding heading to
kaito's village entirely the government
in reality is more than equipped to find
us i instead would work on finding some
other way to find more hidden agents
throughout the country as they are
obviously better than we are at hiding
themselves such as by searching the
online forums through a vpn like the
sponsor of today's video i'm kidding
calm down but i would consider going
through the dark web through an onion
browser to discover other engines out
there an onion browser is simply a
worldwide network of servers that will
pass our data through different servers
giving us better levels of internet
privacy and freedom now that we are one
of them finding other agents should be
our main objectives before anything else
k then gets a phone call from his
sister's phone number but the person on
the other line is the man in the hat who
says he has his sister and that if he
wants to find out why they have her
phone he needs to come and meet him now
kay then dashes off as he takes kaito's
bike driving it for hours until it
finally runs out of gas but he doesn't
let this stop him as he continues the
journey on foot hours later kay walks
tired and dehydrated as he wanders if
he'll die from dehydration and that's
when he finally reaches the meet-up
point this meeting is going to cost him
his life more times than he will ever
want to know here sits the famous ajin
sato and his second minion in command mr
douchebag who sato helped break out of a
government lab earlier sato is a man
that you don't want to mess with and he
wants kate to join him and his group who
he claims are trying to live a peaceful
life k wants to know their secret and
how they get by his people with normal
lives and lucky for k sato mentions that
his sister is also safe and back at the
hospital but something is not right as
kay senses something is nearby we
finally found some of jinns which is
good but we can't trust them just yet
especially after what they did to our
sister desperate times i'm sure but why
would they kidnap someone close to us
just to get our attention into meeting
them unless they directly want something
from us and this right here is a red
flag and despite what sato told us about
wanting to live peacefully bullcrap we
don't have much choice right now other
than to keep an eye on them and to not
trust them fully just yet even if
they're technically rescuing us let's
stay sharp all of a sudden a blow dart
zips past them it's the police and all
three agents take cover however k is
shot in the chest and then quickly
passes out but then as kay's sleeping
body lays there sato and mr douchebag
smile there weren't any cops nearby and
it turns out that it was mr douchebags
black ghost who shot k the only way to
learn how savage humans really are is by
going through the most horrifying
experience that kaye will ever know and
this is sato's plan k wakes up bound to
a table and his entire body is covered
in bandages and restraints this is truly
horrifying kaye can barely make out the
sharp tools and knives circling around
the room kay notices that this is an
operating theater and he's the star of
the show these surgeons are definitely
not board certified as kay screams in
horror as he dies over and over and over
again from blood loss organ failure
shock and more as he continues to relive
the very worst day of his life hating
every last human around him and this was
all part of sato's plan ten days later
santo and mr douchebag show up like
knights in freaking armor busting in and
running around like he had a part in the
matrix trilogy grooving past all the
guards and security that this lab throws
at him the guards don't realize that all
of them are about to die as sato is
unstoppable after the horrifying
bloodbath and piles of bodies right
outside sato pops into kay's room and
frees him lying to his face about how he
found them and they set off to escape
but what sato doesn't realize is that
this kid will cost him everything that
he has planned soon enough on the way
out they come across a few terrified
surgeons as sato tries to kill them but
is stopped by k as he accidentally kills
sato in the process okay we just screwed
up in a big way from the way sato killed
that doctor for no reason makes me
pretty darn sure that he'll be very
happy to kill me if i don't comply with
his orders and just because we're a jinn
i would have used this time to grab his
assault rifle and kill him repeatedly
every few seconds while ordering the
doctors next to me to grab any scalpels
or equipment that they have to use on
sato we may not know how to kill him but
we sure as hell can slow down his
healing process by ordering the doctors
to cut off his hands and legs completely
and if they refuse i'll do it myself and
then we're gonna make a run for it and i
think this is doable because they just
saw what happened they know we're
immortal and we have a gun k shouldn't
have just sat there like an idiot and he
especially should have run away from the
exit door as sato was regenerating he
just made things a lot more difficult
oh i'm so
annoyed sato regenerated and now wholly
pissed off he sets off through the room
looking for kay and the rest of the
surgeons as he plans to kill everybody
and now considers k a failure sato says
since ajins can't die he's got other
plans for k if you chop off anagin's
head will the head that grows back in
its place be the same person or will
kay's consciousness remain in the
chopped off head this is what sato plans
to find out and this terrifies kaye who
is running out of time one of the
doctors with him is not an [ __ ] and
says that he can show k the way out of
the building if he helps them and that's
what k tries to do he tries to outsmart
sato with a crude plan but sato is too
dang old and smart and he beats up k but
also accidentally lets the two doctors
escape k is about to die as sato towers
over him but that's when suddenly k's
black ghost comes out to defend k and
kill sato letting kay barely escape with
his precious young life and no goody for
him and thanks to that nice young doctor
from earlier k follows the lines drawn
on the walls for him to follow leading
him onto the roof however as they make
it near the edge of the building the
doctor is shot by sato and this looks
like the end as sato corners him but kay
is able to bring out his black ghost
once again to defend himself this stun
sato as ajin shouldn't be able to bring
out their black ghost more than one or
two times per day and that's when seto
lets out his terrifying black ghost and
these two monsters battle it out to the
death throwing floating jabs and
stinging slashes at one another the two
black ghosts duke it out as this gives
kaye enough time to throw the injured
doctor off the roof towards safety and
kate jumps down into the passing river
this doctor is a sweetheart so let's use
him as a distraction and get away from
sato kay did mostly everything right
except for a few things now i couldn't
tell you high up exactly we are on the
building but i'm pretty darn sure we're
at least higher than four stories which
would be 48 feet this height is the
medium lethal distance according to the
book trauma anesthesia that gives us at
least a 50 chance of death from falling
from such a height and if anything i
think we're around 7 stories or higher
which gives us a 90 chance of death this
means that i would have used these odds
to distract sato with my angel doctor as
he dies before releasing my black ghost
on him which meant i could have gone up
fully healed in seconds before jumping
into the river nearby from a much safer
height watching kaye's escape unfold on
the security cameras white-haired guy
gets a call from his boss and says that
his job is now at stake and unless he
wants to lose it he better stop letting
ajin's escape left and right white
haired guy also finds out that the world
is conducting inhumane experiments on
ajins for medical purposes and that
aegins have many uses for society from
making drugs to body armor weaponry and
much more this makes white-haired guy
furious and he decides to take matters
into his own hands and kidnaps the big
shot agent expert at gunpoint meanwhile
sato and mr douchebag go to the front of
the lap which is surrounded by news
cameras and tells the reporters that
he's planning a government protest rally
in a few days for agents a peaceful
protest he also releases a secret video
to the whole world showing that the
government inhumanely tortures ajins
this shocks the world and everyone falls
for what sato says not knowing that
believing him will result in many
innocent deaths soon enough a few days
later the protest takes place at the
ministry however not many people are
there including sato although his black
ghost is there and so are a bunch of
other scary-looking black ghost
invisible to the public here sato's
ghost then tells them the location of
the real ajin meeting at the real
meeting all the aegins in japan have
gathered falling for sato's master plan
to come out of hiding to hear what plans
he has for their kind and that was their
biggest mistake hold on has anyone else
thought that maybe this guy is a
complete nut job no one knows that we
are a jins which means we could have
held the meeting at least somewhere oh i
don't know more private even if our kind
is wanted by the police it's a little
weird that sato felt the need to hold a
meeting in an abandoned warehouse going
to an unknown place away from any sort
of public eye is always a risky
situation and the fact that sato invited
us here means that he is holding all the
cards and in theory if something goes
wrong then what's to stop sato from
kidnapping us right here no one's around
here to help us who knows what this
dirty old man will do to us if we don't
like his plans he's in ajin after all
which means we can't trust anyone around
here we see except ourselves elsewhere
white-haired man sits with the kidnapped
ajin researcher and interrogates him
asking him everything there is to know
about ajins we find out this is personal
for him as he wants to know how to use
their abilities for his own gain helping
his wife somehow wake up from her coma
here we learn all the various things
that makes ajins unique how each black
ghost is different from the other how
rain makes it harder for aegins to
control their black ghosts and that they
have no cerebral limit and that a gins
communicate to black ghosts via special
electromagnetic waves that they give off
white-haired guy listens to every last
word that this guy says as he prepares
for the wrath and hellstorm that sato
will bring upon japan very soon as every
day they waste is another day that the
ajins have to mobilize their armies as
they prepare to eventually kill every
single human in the world later on k
washes up on some random shore far away
from tokyo but then on his way into the
forest he bumps into an old lady not
wanting to seem suspicious by running
away he helps the old lady back to her
house and plays it cool okay this old
grandma is suspicious and a problem but
kaye did good by not raising any
suspicions what we should do next is to
head back to her house and lay the old
lady down on her chair or bed for a nap
and gently and tenderly choke her to
death violent and cruelty to the old
people yes i know but hey this will
allow us to use her house as a means of
a temporary shelter we have no idea
where we are as of yet so you know what
question her on everything there is to
know about this area and its people and
maybe her atm details before killing her
now the good thing is that k should have
realized when he was being tortured that
a gin can regenerate their own vitamins
and minerals coming back to life good as
new post death this means in theory that
we don't need food or water to survive
back at the ajin meeting sato reveals
his diabolical plans he's going to use
the citizens to make them hate the
government and then by using that very
same hate as a means of traction to
commit terrorist attacks all over the
world starting with one pharmaceutical
company in central tokyo that he plans
to blow up this company is known for
conducting experiments on a gin he even
records and declares to the world that
he will destroy the pharmaceutical
company in a few days and that this is
only the start of his reign of terror
okay this is insane we need to get out
of here and not only is this old man
nuts he is out on a quest for vengeance
that will do nothing but stir up more
[ __ ] the problem that i have with this
plan is that any time one group decides
to take matters into their own hands the
responsibility of making a good
impression towards others will rely
mainly on that group's ability of
showing themselves in a positive light
deciding to massacre groups of people
throughout japan will do nothing but
rally the humans against us even more so
so bad plan and that is giving what the
government wants making ajin seem even
more deadly than they are i'm willing to
bet there's a lot of undiscovered aegins
out there but i know that there are way
more humans out there than a gin and if
they all want us to die then we will be
beyond outnumbered which is why we need
to leave now not everyone at the meeting
is as evil as sato claiming that doing
this will make the world hate a jinns
instead but sato is too much of a tyrant
to listen and orders mr douchebag to put
the disagreeing agents to bed however
this red haired dude escapes before he
gets captured and takes the first train
out of crazy town back at this old
lady's house kaye nervously checks out
the place knowing that he cannot let her
find out who he is and that at any
moment the government could show up to
kill him he can't afford to relax but
turns out that this old lady reveals to
kate that she knows who he is because
she saw him on the news but that k
reminds her of her own grandson so lucky
for him he can stay at her house for as
long as he wants later on red-haired kid
reaches back to his apartment all
covered in his own blood from earlier
but this lady thinks he's already dead
as she tries to call him an ambulance
and to top it off the government already
knows who he is thanks to his picture
being identified at the protest rally
earlier this kid's in trouble red-haired
kid makes a dash for it knowing that if
he is caught he will never see the light
of day again and will forever be
tortured to death over and over again he
then jumps forward and lands badly
injuring himself just as he crosses path
with white-haired guy and his assistant
white-haired guy then runs him over
about to capture him until the ambulance
arrives picking up and in fact rescuing
red-haired kid from the government's
clutches he later sneakily escapes from
the ambulance by playing dead well my oh
my this cake could not have been luckier
and it's a good thing that that helpful
neighbor of his was shocked enough to
call the ambulance but i suspect we
could have done this a little better red
haired kid chose the wrong day to wear
yellow pants that's for sure [ __ ] but
honestly he did the best that he could
have done without taking off his shirt
it's highly unusual to go shirtless in
japan unless you're at the pool or beach
and this ain't no american college
campus so really red-haired kid would
have dragged more attention coming back
without wearing anything at all but he
didn't have to delay the inevitable of
dying a slow death at the very end of
his chase it's clear that the people
after him were no average gangsters and
that the government has now caught on to
our real ajin identity so i would have
wasted no time thinking we could have
talked this out i do want to note that
red-haired kid is on the seventh floor
red-haired kid could have simply jumped
down as soon as he smelled a whiff of
trouble one this gives you a great way
to get to the ground level real fast and
two he would not have been injured when
white-haired man found him and could
have ran away in full control of the
situation rather than being rescued by
the ambulance later on near grandma's
place kay in his peaceful environment
works on finding out everything there is
to know about his powers conducting his
very own experiments on his ajin and
seeing just what the hell he can truly
do and that's when he hears some
ruffling in the bushes red-haired kid
pops out from hiding as k kills him
first before realizing that he's another
friendly ajin however k doesn't trust
him and poisons him before beating the
ajin out of him and capturing him no one
can know where k is this was incredibly
smart and well done on kay's part bravo
even if this kid has good intentions we
don't know if he's being followed and
chances are anyone who traveled this far
out of tokyo is going to be in some sort
of trouble this is the very same kind of
trouble that we want to avoid what i
would do next is to time up and hide him
and keep my head low for the next few
days for good measure if anyone did
follow him then it's either the
government pairs of dangerous thugs or
other agents i don't know or care i just
don't want to be found kaye explains to
trapped red-haired guy that he's living
in peace right now and has no interest
in stopping sato or fighting anyone this
angers red-haired kid as he knows what's
at stake if k doesn't listen to him that
the city of tokyo will be the first to
fall with thousands dead if no one stops
sato from destroying japan meanwhile
sato is already well underway planning
his greatest terrorist attack yet
getting supplies and help from all the
other agents who plan to reign terror on
the country of japan within a few days
sato's crew then dresses up as regular
old workers heads to the headquarters of
the pharmaceutical company slipping past
security and planting bombs all around
inside setting up the most terrifying
terrorist attack in the history of japan
the day of the bombing comes and the
government is on high alert and has even
placed extra security around the
pharmaceutical building and they've even
implemented special measures thanks to
what white hair dude found out from the
ajin expert as they release a
surrounding wall of water droplets from
numerous pipes all around the building
but it's already too late and now
thousands will die sato arrives killing
guards and receptionists as he heads to
the top of the building just in time for
the grand show but sato isn't at the
pharmaceutical building turns out he's
at the building next door an eruption
then goes off and a massive terrifying
explosion swallows the entire building
whole and sato rides the collapsing
building down as it crashes on top of
the pharmaceutical building as everyone
in both buildings thousands of innocent
people die in a matter of seconds it's a
bloodbath and smoke covers the entire
area as sato wakes up and with a special
shotgun package preparing to take on
what's to come an elite unit from the
metropolitan special assault team sato
live streaming this battle prepares to
show the world who is better the best of
the best of humans or in a jinn and this
is one battle that neither of them can
afford to lose gunshots go off as satu
is killed on site and the assault team
begins to prepare to carry him out on a
stretcher continuously shooting him
every three seconds to prevent him from
coming back to life but this was all
part of sato's plan okay now while these
dudes seemingly have control of this
ajin down pat their coordination and
timing is impeccable baby claps for them
i uh however can't help but wonder as to
why they didn't think to try other
methods other than the simplest ones to
keep him down it's noted that the gins
begin to regenerate at their exact time
of death and what japan's finest decided
to do while simplistic seemed almost too
tedious and risky i would have suggested
maiming sato without killing him such as
conducting a very small neurosurgical
operation on the spot by severing the
connection in the brain's prefrontal
cortex or some other more extreme yet
precise method to make sato's brain dead
or unable to function without killing
him like k being injured time and time
again and the gin doesn't regenerate
until they are dead which means if we
are able to prevent them from dying
whilst keeping them incapacitated it's
safe to say that this method would be
more viable and long-lasting than simply
shooting him every three seconds as they
carry him out on a stretcher because the
moment he dies we're on the clock before
he comes back from the dead to try and
kill us and that's a risk i don't want
to take suddenly the assault team begins
to get shot from a distance as the best
of the best get killed on the spot by a
sniper turns out that sato arranged for
two of his aegin henchmen to cover him
from the rooftops the assault team
panics as they tried their very best to
prevent sato from waking up as they
tried to continue to move him towards a
special vehicle parked in the distance
as they have their very own sniper team
who try and take out the two ajin
snipers but that's when these two crafty
agents call in mr douchebag as he using
his black ghost terrifyingly kills all
the rooftop snipers to lose focus as
sato finally breaks free and that's when
all hell breaks loose sato wakes up and
uses his shotgun to kill every single
soldier around blood spills everywhere
as no one can seem to stop this ajin he
finally finishes killing the last person
before he calmly walks away showing the
government and the world just how
terrifying he truly is meanwhile kay as
he helps out grandma notices that none
of the other villagers are out and about
and his senses tells him that something
terrifying is coming and that's when he
suddenly gets shot it's the police as
the finest of japan's law force
surrounds him forcing him to bid fake
grandma farewell and takes off into the
forest k tricking the cops darts in the
opposite direction going to where red
hair dude still is trapped and releases
him times have changed and kaye is now
ready to stop sato for good teaming up
with red-haired dude the two boys then
head off but cross paths with more
japanese police and even white-haired
dude himself kay is shot by a blow dart
and is about to pass out but that's when
he summons the terrifying black ghost
which acts independently as k passes out
shocking white-haired dude as his aegen
assistant takes out her own black ghost
as the two ghosts battle it out as this
happens kay and red-haired dude wake up
and they make a break for it kay's black
ghost gets destroyed but amazingly he
just makes another one as kay continues
to make more black ghosts he stunned
white-haired dude the two boys then
escaped to take on sato elsewhere across
the country we see sato in a recording
room telling the world that this was
only the beginning and that the final
wave of ajins will come soon to finally
take over the entire country and if you
don't want an old agent meant to take
over your country like subscribe comment
tell us what you liked what you didn't
like and check out the how to be
playlist down below
peace